hey youtubers is Charlie so big news
Oscar Isaac has officially been cast as
apocalypse in x-men Age of Apocalypse
I'll actually think the movie just
called Apocalypse Now they drop the age
of this video is gonna be a breakdown of
the casting as well as all the things we
know about the movies so far and kind of
how it fits in the x-men timeline in
terms of Days of Future past in first
class in case you forgot Oscar Isaac is
one of the main cast members of Star
Wars Episode seven it's a little too
soon to be calling him the next Chris
Pratt but maybe we can think of him as
like an evil Chris Pratt like a really
small indie actor that blows up suddenly
and ends up playing some of the biggest
villains and the biggest franchises in
history to be clear we don't know
officially what his Star Wars character
is gonna be rumors say he's gonna be
something of like a han solo scoundrel
smuggler type character I'll talk more
about that during my Star Wars trailer
breakdown on Friday today is all about
mutants and we can actually use that
word because this is Fox I get so tired
about all the legal with Fox
using the word mutant and Marvel having
to use the word inhuman to describe
people with special powers and that is
what's happening Marvel is able to do
special powers because they have the
Inhumans it's like a backdoor to mutants
whatever is totally crazy it's just
Hollywood typical type stuff
but here's a breakdown of the characters
in order of importance to the narrative
so first there's Apocalypse the movies
named after him so of course she's the
biggest character it's gonna be about
his life then there's Jennifer
Lawrence's mystique it's possible they
could change her backstory just a little
and make her like a daughter of
apocalypse or related to him somehow the
comics play with her backstory quite a
bit but on screen they tend to simplify
things to a ridiculous degree I know
that sounds really stupid but that's
like Hollywood movie logic for you the
other big character is gonna be back
neato like supposedly mystique and
magneto are much more important to the
narrative of this films and they were at
Days of Future past even though they
were big characters in that movie like
this movie centers on them even more
it's also supposedly going to deal with
their relationship as it applies to the
future the x-men universe like the fact
that they were in a relationship or they
have something between them in terms of
all the other characters everyone from
the first class universe and Days of
Future past is gonna be back all the
young actors or at least the ones that
did not die in Days of Future past in
terms of timeline the movie is going to
take place right after the events of
days of
your past not maybe not right after but
really soon after so if Days of Future
past was a 70s movie think of Age of
Apocalypse is like an 80s movie the last
end credits teaser we saw featured
apocalypse in ancient Egypt so there
will be flashbacks explaining where he
came from I mean the movies gonna tell
his backstory but the majority of the
movie is gonna be in present-day
where it all the characters are adults
the story itself was planned to be like
the next logical step given the events
of Days of Future past
so magneto assaults the president on
live television with all the world
watching he's taken down but where do we
go from there
then we also have to consider that there
was another and credit scene with
Wolverine waking up at a future Xavier
Academy where everyone was still alive
this is where things get a little bit
fuzzy in terms of timeline because if
that future Academy exists it means the
x-men defeat apocalypse so how are they
going to provide dramatic tension in Age
of Apocalypse if we already know what's
gonna happen in the future and the movie
does not do time travel and just to be
clear I don't think there's gonna be any
kind of time travel in Age of Apocalypse
I don't think they're gonna do the exact
same thing two movies in a row Age of
Apocalypse in the comics does deal with
some flash forwards where you see like
the post-apocalyptic version of what
happens when apocalypse takes over the
world I think the movie will address
that I don't know how they're gonna deal
with it if they're not gonna do time
travel I just feel the idea of them
doing to time-travel movies back to back
is a little ridiculous the x-men
franchise is like such a critical part
of Fox's earnings as a company that I
don't think that they'd risk money by
leaving things on a super downer ending
so I think it's kind of implied that the
x-men are gonna fight apocalypse to a
standstill
just think of like whatever ending would
make them the most money like that's
what's gonna be planned that's like a
whole other conversation you know when
is it okay for a franchise movie to have
like a super downer ending
I think Empire Strikes Back is probably
the best example but that's when you
have like a trilogy with a very clear
narrative one that's with the beginning
like the middle and the end is totally
planned out and that's not really how
the x-men franchise works x-men is
really like one movie right after the
other and just depending on how each
movie does the story is adjusted Brent
Singer is the author of Days of Future
past and Age of Apocalypse so they will
tied together but that doesn't
necessarily mean that singer is also
going to write the next x-men film it's
not like they're planning these as a
trilogy so here's a little backstory on
the age
apocalypse story from the comic books
just careful for spoilers if you don't
know anything about the comics this is
gonna be really short though so I'm not
gonna go into super specific details so
if you think of Days of Future past is
like an alternate timeline future where
humanity has tried to kill off mutants
Age of Apocalypse is like the other side
of that story the world is taken over by
apocalypse with the aid of his four
horsemen and mr. sinister it's a lot
more complicated than that but I mean if
you want to read about it
get the comic it's totally amazing even
though apocalypse views himself as a
champion for mutants he's in so much a
pusher for mutant rights like magneto he
preaches survival of the fittest so all
you have to do is be able to kill all
the other people around you if you can
survive in his new world order then
you'll get his respect so just because
you're a mutant doesn't automatically
make you part of his new world order
magneto on the other hand would probably
accept you regardless of what your
alignment is as long as your mutant
that's just a cursory explanation in the
comic book storyline I fully expect the
movie to change a lot of that Days of
Future past the movie changed a lot of
stuff about Days of Future past from the
comics same thing is gonna happen with
the new movie one thing they could do to
keep the movie in present day without
having to deal with time-travel is just
show that creation of the four horsemen
and like the x-men fighting apocalypse
and mr. sinister to a standstill just in
terms of duration I think the movies
probably to be about as long as Days of
Future past was which is a little over
two hours so they'll have plenty of time
to do a whole side story for apocalypse
and his four horsemen mr. sinister
himself is not confirmed as a character
in the movie I really hope we see him
though just because he's really
interesting and speaking about new
characters they're recasting a whole
bunch of the x-men that we've already
seen the people they're swapping out are
like the big main x-men characters but
the ones that we did not see in first
class so like Cyclops Jean Grey the
other x-men that were really big in the
comics but that haven't been really big
in the new rebooted movies I know they
had young Cyclops and Wolverine Origins
but think about them casting like bigger
versions like more a-list mainstream
actors so that also brings up the issue
of Channing Tatum's gambit because that
character is getting his own solo movie
just cast Channing Tatum that's in
production supposedly he's not going to
be featured in the Age of Apocalypse
movie it's possible they could tease him
I mean it makes sense from a market
standpoint but his character isn't
supposed to be a big part of the film
even though in the comics he did become
one of apocalypses horseman death
specifically in the original comic
though that was worn wardington everyone
asking about Taylor Kitsch playing
gambit yes I think if John Carter hadn't
been such an epic bomb he would still be
playing gambit channing tatum on the
other hand right now is guaranteed box
office for fox i'm just gonna wait till
I see official footages and images from
the gambit movie to pass judgment I'm a
big Channing Tatum fan but I have no
idea what he's gonna look like his
gambit the apocalypse movie isn't coming
till May 2016 so there's a lot of time
to get ready the fun part now is
actually just catching up on Apocalypse
in the comics the first thing I think
you guys should check out like if you
want to read up on apocalypse is the
original Age of Apocalypse comic book
like I said though they're probably
gonna change a lot of it it's not gonna
be a straight-up adaptation he's a big
part of x-men access right now like
that's actually going down right now
it's a really good comic even by itself
even without apocalypse then there's the
90s animated series totally awesome I
think it's still on Netflix right now so
you should be able to check it out they
did an Age of Apocalypse storyline like
I think it was a two-part episode I
don't have a lot of background with the
Hellfire Club
but apocalypse did meet mr. sinister
through the Hellfire Club and the x-men
movies have already done Hellfire Club
in first class so it's possible that
they could bring that back on the new
film so if you have any recommendations
about Hellfire Club specific storylines
please recommend them in the comments so
here's my big question for you guys do
you think that box because it has both
Fantastic Four and the x-men should try
to do a shared universe like Marvel or
do you think that would be a huge pile
of fail and you just want Marvel to do
it and no one else I will say right now
I do kind of like that Marvel is the
only one that's doing it I don't want to
see everyone in the universe start to do
it Marvel is making a ton of money right
now they're super successful but I don't
think that everyone else is gonna be
able to pull it off like I don't want to
see a spider-man shared universe I'd
rather see them alone spider-man to
Marvel but lots of x-men stuff coming in
the next couple years so feel free to
leave me x-men bonus video requests in
the comments really big reminders though
Star Wars trailer breakdown coming on
Friday be sure to subscribe to get that
I'm also gonna be posting my Walking
Dead Q&A later tonight then I'll post my
Gotham finale video so much awesome
stuff happening right now in case you
haven't seen me
talk about it I have new mobile links up
here in case you're watching on your
mobile phone or on a tablet is the same
as the links over here but click here to
learn all about that Star Wars trailer
that's coming and click here for my
x-men Days of Future Passed review and I
really need to start like an x-men
playlist and do more x-men videos thank
you so much for watching though so let's
all high-five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you